What's up, mystical wanderers?
Welcome to the podcast.
So, it's been a minute,
but today, keeper of the flame,
prophetess of all things metaphysical Julie Piatt,
AKA SriMati,
returns to swim in the holy waters of the unworldly.
For those new or newer to the show,
Julie is my wife.
She's my partner of 21-plus years.
She's also a best-selling vegan cookbook author.
She's the founder and CEO of SriMu,
the best plant-based cheese in the known universe.
She's host of the "For the Life of Me" podcast.
She's the ethereal matriarch
of the online spiritual community Water Tiger.
She's also a musician, a yogi, a healer,
an entrepreneur, a mother, all the things.
But before we dive in,
today's episode is brought to you
by the Plantpower Meal Planner,
taking all the hassle out of optimal nutrition
with everything you need to finally master your plate.
More on this later,
but for now visit meals.richroll.com
to sign up and use promo code RRHEALTH at checkout
for $10 off an annual membership.
So, this one is about many things,
but I think mostly it's about the importance
of facing the hidden within,
why it's so crucial to work through
those uncomfortable secrets that we all harbor.
Because truly,
there is nothing more powerful than owning your truth
and nothing more profound than to truly know oneself.
So, hit that subscribe button, hit the like button.
Leave your thoughts in the comment section below.
And without further ado, let's take that wavelength higher.
Well, welcome to the new studio.
It's your first experience here.
It feels so professional.
I know, it's crazy, right?
It's really beautiful, it's really amazing.
Well, as the person who was there for episode one
in the warehouse in Kauai,
it's definitely come a long way.
There is a trajectory, definitely a profound journey.
We're not gonna hear rain on the roof today.
We might hear some-
Construction, maybe.
Next door, there's quite a bit of construction going on.
I think we've worked it out.
We got a detente happening
so that we get some quiet time for recording.
But that's just the reality.
That's great.
It's super beautiful.
Good to see you.
Thank you for coming back.
It's been a minute.
It's been a while.
We are now at the one-year mark of the pandemic.
It's true.
It's been a year, but we are in,
when this airs, we will be in daylight savings,
which is why I wore my spring best for today,
to celebrate the sun.
Counting the days to daylight savings?
Until it's summer again.
And here we are once again,
creating a formal structure
so that we can actually communicate with each other,
even though we cohabitate.
It's the secret to a healthy and transformative marriage.
Start a podcast, yeah.
Create a bunch of infrastructure around when you talk
so that you can have some healthy communication.
Hopefully we talk not on the podcast.
Once in a while.
But it's easy for life to get transactional.
We have six people at our house right now.
There's a lot of moving pieces.
And with young people,
everybody's been dealing with the setbacks of this moment
in different ways,
and it requires our full attention most of the time.
So, it's easy to not shine the spotlight
on our relationship and go on autopilot.
We've probably had intervals of autopilot
in our relationship because of the other demands
on our time and our energy with our children
and our respective businesses.
We're both super busy.
But here we are.
We can actually talk.
How do you think we're doing?
I always, I always open-
You always ask me!
Well, give me a temperature check.
I think that marriages are living, breathing entities
and they are moving and evolving and changing all the time.
And so, it's not about any static state of being.
And yeah, I think we've had more,
definitely more stretches of autopilot
probably than ever before.
But I think right now,
all of us are going through
huge, huge levels of transformation.
And it seems like every single person in our household
and every single person that I know,
this experience of forced sort of sequestration
is providing a soil or an opportunity for us
to be with ourselves
and to maybe explore and reflect on certain things
that I think we all hide from ourselves,
from our relationships, and from society.
I certainly do.
Well, it's a weird thing because on the one hand,
we all feel static,
like we can't move, we can't navigate the world
the way that we're used to.
We're stuck at home.
And so, it feels like we're revving the engine in park.
But there is that opportunity.
Whether we take advantage of that opportunity or not
is up to us.
But I do think that there's tremendous change happening
in the context of being told to sit still, right?
Which is so uncomfortable, it's so hard.
Definitely, and also just amidst so much loss and turmoil
and the chaos of the world,
and the fact that you can't travel your way
to escape the status quo, what's going on.
I feel like it is a necessity, actually.
It's a requirement if we're going to stay here.
And transitioning and leaving your body
is another form of evolution.
It's another form of taking another fork in the road
or another journey into more life, into more experience.
But I feel like it is absolutely required of us
to clear out anything that is not in alignment
with who we are.
Anything that we have been hiding,
we're gonna have to look at it.
If we don't, I think the universe will knock a little harder
until we pay attention.
It tends to do that, annoyingly so.
So, just so people can get a visual,
you're looking beautiful today.
Aww, thank you!
One thing that I've noticed that you have done
is you've really doubled down on your,
not just your meditation practice,
but your devotion to ritual.
So much so that our bedroom has been transformed
into one gigantic altar
where you can't even actually walk in the room.
You gotta tiptoe around various artifacts
and sacred objects that you've peppered all over the space.
And as people know,
I sleep in a tent and then I come up in the morning,
and then you're in your sacred moment.
And you're surrounded by, it continues to metastasize.
It's getting more to the extent
that I came in the other night and I tripped over,
it was dark and I tripped over something.
And it's like I can't even move in here anymore.
There's too many spiritual artifacts happening in here.
And it seems like your practice has been elongated.
It used to be maybe a half an hour.
Then it went to an hour.
But you're up in your quiet moments now
for sometimes the better part of an entire day,
which I always find interesting and also confounding
as the CEO and founder of a startup food company.
Like, how are you running your company
when you're in basically in a silent meditation retreat
ensconced in the bedroom?
It's a mystery.
Ah, the mystery,
the mystery of working less and accomplishing more.
Well, first of all-
You're moving the tectonic plates of the universe
with your spirit and your mind.
Exactly, with really,
okay, so there's a few things.
First of all, I just need to say
it's not an all-day retreat, actually,
because I rise so much earlier.
You know, that might be from 2:00 a.m. to 7:00 a.m.
About seven, I have to move
and get the girls up and be a mom.
I woke up in the middle of the night the other night
because the pungent smell of your sacred fire
burning in the yard was so strong
that it awakened me from a deep sleep.
I don't know what you were burning in there,
but it was something very-
It's speaking to you.
Very strong.
It's entering your smell.
And so, what are you doing, specifically?
Really, what I'm finding very, very amplified
is the ability to embody presence
and to really sit inside of my being
in that feeling consciousness that animates this body
with a level of presence that I haven't experienced.
So, it's more,
I would say that if there is a focus, that's the focus.
But along with that are many ritual practices which
include receiving the body as sacred.
So, for instance, if I get up,
I might, before I'm gonna chant,
I would wash my mouth.
I would wash my face, my hands, my feet.
Maybe I would even, I could even bathe fully.
But I don't often do all that.
So, it's about this reverence for this instrument,
this dress, or this vehicle that is housing the spirit.
And I really feel that this time is about embodiment.
I am a householder.
I didn't incarnate.
I'm not in a cave.
I'm a mother of many children
and a business entrepreneur and wife.
And so, it's about being embodied
with your spirit in this life, in this modern place.
And I need those or I crave those
or I receive nourishment from that kind of communion.
And even now, more than ever,
it is the thing that I can count on.
You know, life is changing.
The only thing that we know is everything is gonna change.
Everything material will change.
Every relationship, every career, every building,
every single station of identity will shift.
And the one thing that is constant
is that consciousness that is animating this.
And so, I have a great desire to be closer to her,
to really, really know her.
And so, that's what I'm doing.
And so, what have you learned
over the course of the past year
by really doubling down on this devotional commitment?
Well, I think it is,
as is well-shared in many spiritual seekers' path
and life experiences,
that we really know nothing.
And so, when people talk about their beliefs
or they get very attached to a certain
intellectual idea or truth,
I try not to believe.
I try not to have a belief
and I try to exist in a state of being
where I can spontaneously respond to life
in a way that is in alignment for me.
So, for instance, like in my spiritual mentorship group
that I lead called Water Tiger,
I'm not sharing about manifesting,
about getting what you want.
I'm sharing about aligning with who you are.
And this brings me back to my subject of hiding.
I say this often.
There is nothing more beautiful
than a being that knows itself.
There is nothing more intoxicating, inspiring, powerful
than a being that is sitting inside of itself
very authentically with a lot of truth.
And so, it's not about manifesting or grabbing
or getting or competing.
It's about aligning with the truth of who you are
so that you can spontaneously interact with life
in a way that is authentic to you,
in alignment for you.
And I feel that there's a great likelihood
that that will cause benefit.
It will create benefit.
Not only to me or not only to us,
I mean, to whoever's on this journey.
But to life itself in all its different forms
It's a becoming as opposed to a,
what would be the antithesis of that?
I would say it's a being,
it's a beingness instead of a gettingness,
instead of a-
It is a powerful thing when somebody walks into a room
and that person is living their life
in alignment with their values.
There is a palpable, powerful aura around that person.
You know it immediately.
And I think it is,
I think that's the quest that we should all be on, right?
I think that that process has become complicated
by a wired culture in which we're so interconnected
such that when an issue arises,
rather than sitting with yourself
to figure out how you truly feel about X, Y, or Z,
you can go on Twitter and just canvass
all these opinions of all these people and then decide,
well, I kind of like that guy,
so I guess I see it the way that he or she sees it.
Which is a short-cutting of the real process
of trying to understand from first principles,
what is this really about?
How does this sit with me?
What are my values?
Where does this align or not align
with my basic disposition?
And yes, agreed.
It also leads to,
if you're going to agree with somebody's belief system,
and so, let's say you're scrolling through Twitter
and you're like, Rich said oak tree,
so I'm gonna say oak tree.
So, I'm gonna go and I'm gonna be oak tree with Rich.
The second that Rich says something that is not oak tree,
now you villainized Rich because suddenly,
wait, I don't,
Rich is now saying oak tree and orange,
but I'm not saying oak tree and orange.
I think it's oak tree and apple,
so now let me cancel Rich.
Let me just cancel him and make him irrelevant.
And so, this is the sort of comedy
I find in the culture of the human condition
to seek this consensus.
I also find it very curious how willing humans are
to annihilate another human so readily
when we are so flawed.
All of us have had dark moments in our life,
have made missteps.
It touches me deeply.
It feels very, very delicate to me, very fragile,
and almost like it's a danger
to really step into criticizing somebody
or making fun of somebody.
It's like we are all,
we all at some aspect are one.
We all have many different flavors,
completely unique flavors that we're sharing.
But can't we just let that go, let that consensus go
and understand that everybody's different,
and find what is in alignment for us individually
and live from that state?
Not having to make someone else wrong.
It doesn't make any sense.
That's hard work, though.
It's much easier to say,
listen, as human beings, we're hardwired.
We like to celebrate certain people and build them up,
and then we enjoy the schadenfreude of tearing them down.
And this is the cycle that we're seeing
accelerated across the board
in every camp and village and ideology.
And it is disheartening.
I, too, kind of look at it like,
I've done all kinds of crazy stuff.
I don't wanna be judged in that way.
And I don't feel it's incumbent upon me
to judge anybody else in that regard.
But I think the question would be,
why do we feel compelled to tear people down
in such a villainous manner?
And if I had to estimate,
I think it has something to do with the fact
that if you haven't done that internal work
to really know who you are,
then your sense of identity is somewhat fragile.
And it is sort of dependent upon this latticework
of these other people out there
and what they think and how they see the world.
And if that person changes their mind,
that becomes a threat to your sense of self or identity,
because that sense of self is fragile
and not as robust as it would be
if you engaged in that process of self-understanding.
Yeah, definitely.
And I mean, to me,
it's all question of spiritual connection.
It's like we're not feeding the spiritual connection
as the first point of entry.
Spiritual connection is not the 20th thing
you do on the list.
It's the first thing.
It's the thing that informs everything else about your life.
And so, having been somebody who's been marginalized
most of my life and labeled as crazy or cute or trite,
or, "Isn't that ridiculous that she has that view,"
to me, it's intelligent.
I mean, I just want the least amount of suffering
for myself and for humanity.
And so, the place where that redemption lies,
or that solace or that care or that love and compassion,
is in spiritual connection, direct spiritual connection,
which we don't need a priest or an ism or a religion
or anybody's permission to have it.
We have it inherently.
So, how does somebody who is listening to this
and is feeling some resonance with what you just said,
but has no experience
with any kind of a spiritual connection,
how do you translate that
into something actionable for that individual?
Well, I think what's needed are techniques, okay?
There's a lot of conversations,
like conversation we're having now.
Conversations can be really meaningful.
Your show has literally been,
it's been transcen, transformative.
You were gonna say transcendental.
Transcendental, I was like, no, transformative.
Not quite, then, transcendental.
No, I think it definitely has been
for many, many, many people.
So, I'm not saying that conversation isn't helpful.
It is.
But when you get down to it,
you can't really know something that you read in a book
or that you hear somebody else say.
You have to experience it for yourself.
Which is why life experience is so valuable,
all kinds of life experiences.
But I think it's the techniques of meditation,
of yoga nidra, of sitting in tea ceremony, of being present.
It's the will, it's the calling to divine.
It's the choosing to experience life as a divine journey
that cultivates these energetic experiences
that become a knowing inside of you.
And then when you have the knowing, you're really,
there's a saying that truth doesn't defend, it simply is.
So, here you are in the state of being.
A being who's rooted in being
isn't gonna go fight for peace
or argue about which political party.
It's like there's a power in staying quiet, staying quiet.
I'm not saying you don't do anything
and you go to a cave and you don't live.
But staying quiet until you're really aligned
with what is true for you.
And if you're really aligned with that,
then you can really be effective in your actions,
in your politics, in your love for planet earth,
in whatever you're doing.
But if you've never taken the time to know yourself,
you're not there.
You're just spouting off what someone else says.
You're retweeting something,
thinking that you did something good.
And this is Water Tiger.
This is my spiritual mentorship program,
is a body of techniques.
It's a way to no way.
I'm not claiming to know what anybody's path is.
I'm been down the road a few years
and I've spent a lot of time in study in these areas
in this lifetime and also in other lifetimes.
So, I offer some body of techniques that may help people.
It is helping people.
They are helping people to access
a connection with themselves
which is a direct connection with source.
So, in the process of being engaged
with this community on Water Tiger,
and I know you do these private sessions
with lots of people,
what are the things that are coming up?
What are the common themes?
What are people struggling with and experiencing right now
in this one-year demarcation of the pandemic?
Well, it's profound.
I mean, I think I'll share, you know-
And obviously you can't-
I can't share who it is.
But I'll share generally about
the last two sessions that I facilitated, actually.
One is a Water Tiger member
and one is on their way to becoming a Water Tiger member.
There's real life happening to all of us right now.
One of the experiences is an individual
whose friend hung himself,
and he's the one who went in and found him.
So, that was one experience that I facilitated
an empowerment, a love, a blessing,
a sort of reformatting perspective
so that we can extract the treasure from such horror.
That's one, and I'll get into,
some of what I've gleaned from these
is very profound right now,
and also connected to the essence of SriMu
and what that is to me,
is this opportunity to find beauty in all life.
And you might be thinking,
well, how in the hell could you find beauty
in such a horrific event for all individuals involved?
You know, that's somebody's child,
that's somebody's brother, it's somebody's lover,
it's somebody's friend.
It's so final.
You can't change that.
It's something that, to me in my experience,
is the opportunity to render us on our knees.
And for the very quality of that experience,
it is a divine experience beyond measure
because it's maybe one of the only experiences
that we can't reason our way out of.
We can't quantify it or say something positive or change it.
It's so final in this realm.
Another experience from a Water Tiger member
is an artist that has worked with me,
and we're exploring beauty
as the first tenet of a spiritual life.
So, you may look at me from the outside and say,
well if she was really spiritual,
why does she wear makeup and why does she fix her hair?
Why is she wearing a dress?
Or, why did she create SriMu that's this big,
beautiful, aesthetically developed product?
And the reason is because beauty is the first tenet
of a spiritual life.
That is what makes us connected to life around us.
And so, within my ritual,
within my practices of coaching people and helping people,
I am helping us to remember that we have the power
to find beauty in all life experiences.
This other artist that I was working with,
that I'm working with,
she's been asking for a communication
about her role as being a steward of sacred art.
And we're talking about the ability
to program art with intention,
to be in ritual and communion
before we start to create the art.
And how could we use art as a vehicle
of beauty being the first tenet of spirituality
that can transform the planet,
that can lift our experience of life here by healing us,
by feeding us, by nourishing us?
And she had a very visceral transcendental experience
using the Water Tiger techniques.
And she had a complete,
she was given a body of work exactly the way it looks
in exactly the format and the date
that she needs to do it by and all these kind of things.
And also, very connected to some deep suffering
in her journey that she had to face.
That was very probably the thing
that was the hardest thing for her.
In my work, the greatest treasure is in the trauma.
And so, when I work with somebody,
I'm looking for the thing they never told anybody.
I may be the first person that they shared it with.
Or the thing that is absolutely irreconcilable.
And if I am lucky enough and blessed enough
to serve my purpose,
by the end of that session,
they have a different perspective on the events.
Right, and that tracks back to this idea
that we began this conversation with,
which is this thing where there's,
everybody has something that they're hiding from
or that they're hiding from the world
or that they're hiding from themselves.
And to the extent that you can muster the courage
to actually look at that, to deconstruct that,
and find the gem or the meaning or the beauty
or the opportunity in that,
that's where the crux of transformation begins.
And this has always been your thing with me.
And when we weathered
all of our challenges and difficulties,
it's like, how do we flip this
and look at it from a perspective of opportunity
rather than victimhood?
Like, "Why is this happening to me?
"Isn't this terrible?"
Instead, like, "This is your divine moment."
Like, "This is the opportunity
"that you've been waiting for."
And just that mental shift,
as difficult as that might be
or as counterintuitive or challenging
to inhabit that in your body,
I've found that to be incredibly powerful.
I've seen you do that in the context of our family
and I've seen you do that with so many other people.
And it is maybe the hardest thing you'll ever do,
but also carries that potential energy
for the change that people are yearning for.
Definitely.
And "Let it be beautiful" is sort of one of my mantras.
It's like, let it be beautiful, whatever,
it may be scary.
It's not autopilot.
It's not acting like everything is the same.
It's not getting to a place and saying,
"We're here and now we're here,
"and we're gonna be a static form
"for the rest of our lives because we're here."
Doesn't work that way.
It's always changing.
And no matter how difficult,
whatever the evolution is,
whatever needs to be looked at,
it has to be beautiful.
It has to be beautiful because life is divine.
It's sacred.
This is a privilege.
It's a divine privilege to be in a body at this time.
And we are co-creating our experience with our life.
And so, rather than hide
from what is bubbling inside of you
or what is beckoning your attention,
why not face it and communicate with it and exchange with it
and create something beautiful from it?
One of the things,
and we've talked about this before,
that I think is powerful but also challenging to me
is this idea that you don't wanna rob someone
of their divine moment, right?
Like, if somebody's going through a hard time
whether it's emotional or financial
or maybe they've experienced the death of a loved one,
or maybe they lost their job,
they can't pay their bills.
Whatever flavor that shows up in,
the idea of,
we have this urge like we wanna step in,
we wanna intervene, we wanna help.
We wanna alleviate the pain.
We wanna solve the problem.
But that's also the opportunity
to step back and allow that person that experience
because there's some lesson that needs to be learned
as a result of running that gauntlet.
And so, it's this tension between,
it's a tension around, how do you best love somebody?
Do you opt out?
And is it more loving to let them have that experience
without your interference?
And at what point do you step in and try to course correct
because you see something going horribly awry?
I think this is a really good question.
And for me, it's less about what you do
and more about the energy with which
you are viewing the individual.
If my friend is bleeding,
I'm gonna get them some bandages
and I'm gonna clean them off and make them safe
and get them food and be like,
"Are you okay?
"Like, you're good?
"Like, I'm here."
I think the real power is in how I'm viewing that person.
Am I choosing to view that person as a casualty?
Or let's say the person was irresponsible and created that.
Let's say, I don't know what a good example.
Let's say they caused that accident
because they are using drugs
and they got in a situation and the accident happened.
I think as powerful healers and co-creators
and beings of a version of a Christic form
or what might be a Christ-embodied,
free from religion, free from isms.
Just from the very nature of being humane,
of being human beings,
we have the ability to hold that person
in their highest vision and say:
It's okay, man, you got this.
I know you stumbled.
I see you as such a beautiful being.
You have so many amazing qualities.
You know, I love this about you.
I love that about you.
And I know you're struggling
and I'm not gonna solve your problem for you.
I'm not going to intervene with my judgment.
I'm just gonna hold you in love,
knowing that this force, God, creation has you
and that you're in your process.
And how does that work for you with parenting?
It gets a little bit trickier.
Yeah, I mean,
and this is a subject that is difficult to talk about
because we actually don't have permission to talk about it.
Right, we're not gonna talk about
our kids specifically, but-
It's the same thing-
But the general idea of,
when are you in the allowing,
when are you in the, "I'm gonna intervene, here?"
Well, trust me, I think it's a dance, right?
And I mean, there's many times I'll just go in
to check on them, to make sure they're there
and they're not hurting themselves and they're fine.
I trust my mother's intuition.
I mean, trust me.
A lot of people are considering,
they have suicidal thoughts.
Especially now, you know,
and especially in our youth.
So, I think you have to keep a close eye.
But I think when you come into judgment
thinking that that's gonna stop the action,
nobody changes in a field of judgment.
People change in a field
of unconditional love and compassion.
And that's not that hard with our kids
because we all adore our kids.
Right, but I think what is happening
is everybody's under duress.
The anxiety levels are through the roof.
People's economic situations are being challenged.
And so, parents are feeling a lot of anxiety
disproportionate to what they're used to.
And without a level, a deep level of awareness,
it's very easy for that anxiety or stress
to leak out onto the children.
And the children are under their own level of duress
with having to do their schooling from home.
And it just becomes this soup
of mental unfitness in which nobody's acting
as well as they would like to act.
And it creates a lot of chaos and problems.
I think we're seeing this epidemic now
of children struggling with how to navigate this world
where their entire life is on screens
and they can't see their friends or go to school.
Parents who are under stress,
they're not happy that their kids are in this situation
and they're trying to work from home.
All of these things are unprecedented
and creating complications
that we haven't developed tools for.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I would say there's always
these opportunities in being a parent.
It's like it's sort of part of the journey.
There's gonna come a point where your child just cancels you
and thinks you're completely outdated and irrelevant.
That's part of the journey.
I'm already there.
Yeah, definitely, we're there.
I always thought I was gonna be the cool dad.
No, that's the illusion.
That's the illusion.
No one is the cool dad to their kids.
No one is the cool mom.
I mean, and I would say on the other side,
there's a lot of benefits from being sequestered
from quarantine that have,
as I'm gonna say, added five years onto our lives.
I mean, possibly saved our children's lives.
Maybe it kept,
maybe they're unhappy and they're kicking dirt,
but they're in a more contained space than they would have.
We aren't God.
We can't see exactly what the journey is.
But you know, listen.
I think it's a great hilarity of the universe
that as a mother,
I give birth to a baby that needs me for every single thing,
like it's this symbiotic union.
And then at some point,
that being grows up and is just like, "Fuck off!"
I mean, it's kind of funny because you're just like,
"What is going on here," you know?
So, that's kind of, I think,
a funny thing from the universe.
But I think that in general,
I think as a culture we hold our kids back too long.
I think they should go into their own living spaces
with communes at age 12, with their own bank accounts,
and they should be treated as adults much sooner
because there's so much turmoil between them
still being in the house.
And like I said, we're cool parents,
and we have it, too.
So, yeah.
I think the unconditional love part, though,
the more you can cultivate that within yourself,
and let's be clear.
It doesn't mean that you don't have preferences.
I can prefer chocolate over vanilla,
but I can still have unconditional love for both flavors.
Where do you feel judgment flaring up in yourself?
Where are the challenges?
Where do you draw the battle lines?
Where's the evolution that you need
to experience for yourself showing up in your life?
Or are you just completely evolved at this point?
No, I mean, one of my big woundings
is being judged and marginalized
for being a spiritual being
with the awareness and perspective that I have.
It's been painful.
There's been times I haven't wanted
to be here on this planet.
As human beings, we want to be seen, we want to connect.
And there's an aspect of me
where I'm always the last one to know.
I don't think I'm that weird at all.
And so, I could snuggle up real close to somebody
thinking that we're good friends,
and then find out later
that they think I'm completely insane.
So, that has been definitely a theme.
And I think that's a theme of anybody
who comes in to create something new.
It's lonely.
It feels lonely.
You know, many, many kids, spectrum kids
who have processes that fire completely different.
I mean, look at Brian who wrote and read backwards
his whole life.
And you know, there's many, many of us.
There's many people.
We're all unique,
and we've been trying to fit into this school system
or these structures that are in the society that say,
"This is what is a smart person
"and this is what is a value person
"and this is what is an educated person."
And then when you really dive deep into all those,
we just find out that none of that's true
and none of it's really working.
And so, again, it brings me back to my spirituality.
I've been known to say, I can count on my devotion.
It brings me a nourishment, a love for life.
It allows me to expand my capacity to love.
And I think that the key for my wounding
has been to love myself more,
to do my meditation practices in the mirror,
to look at what I am, to receive what I am
with everything that I've done.
And I have another layer
that I'm gonna be going into around sexuality.
I've talked about this,
and I guess I was waiting for someone else to do it.
It just came to my awareness
that I'm gonna be one of the ones that rewrites it.
But it's like, for me,
sexuality is the same thing as creativity
is the same thing as spirituality.
And we are wasting our sexual energy with the darkest force.
It is like, think of it.
Sexuality is our super power to transcend,
and it is used by demonic forces in such a bad way.
One of the tragedy,
or one of the difficult things right now
is that if you talk about child abuse,
then suddenly I'm in a QAnon club,
which is really, that is the intention, right?
And just to set the record straight,
I've never watched a QAnon video,
I've never gone to a website.
I've heard things on Twitter.
I deleted my Twitter, though, about a month ago,
and I'm very happy.
But my point is that sexual abuse is happening
as an epidemic on this planet.
How do I know?
I know because probably 90% of my clients
have been abused as children, men and women.
I'm dealing with it firsthand.
My thing is,
regarding to dealing with my head.
A lot of you know that I've suffered
from traumatic head pain for maybe going on 30 years.
It is debilitating.
Sometimes we refer to them as migraines,
but they're not really migraines.
I've been down every single road
trying to unlock this mystery.
And the last two episodes that I had over the last 10 weeks,
I had two in 10 weeks.
I mean, I was sobbing from the pain.
Literally, I'm exhausted from this trajectory.
And what I'm learning is that not from this lifetime,
from a past lifetime,
I have a trauma that I need to go into
to retrieve parts of myself.
And I have the feeling and the inkling that there is,
there are sexual aspects to that.
And these are directly related to me
reclaiming my power as a seer,
as a being that has a more expanded sight
than what I have in this capacity.
And that's gonna be really difficult to look at.
I've been very open about my time of my life
where I had very promiscuous sex when I was in my teens.
I was trying to fulfill this void of my father
and this bad, this, not bad,
but a not good relationship with my dad,
and I was trying to figure it out.
I was trying to find that.
And I hurt myself terribly.
And I think that there's more for me to resolve
from that experience.
The thing is, we can't be our own healers.
I know how to do these processes,
but you need someone else to hold space for that.
And so, it's kind of the last thing
that I haven't looked at.
If I go through this and my headaches don't go away,
I'm gonna just be like "I don't know what to do!"
Right.
It's also your attachment to finding a solution
that I think causes you additional suffering.
No, maybe in,
I would say no, probably no, honey.
I mean, yes, I had a point where I was,
yes, this happened over the last cycle-
Well, there's been a couple times where it's like,
"I think I'm on top of it."
And then you get hit again,
and that disappointment that you experience.
That's true, that's true.
And I just went through that to a great degree, actually,
'cause I did this whole Ayurvedic cleanse
and I was tracking it.
I was like, "I'm on this."
And it came, and I remember I was sobbing in your arms,
and I was saying, "I'm so disappointed."
I remember saying that.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
And I appreciate everyone who sends me,
try this and try this and migraine.
I've tried all of it, let me tell you.
Most of it, I've tried it.
This is been going on for decades.
Well, anybody who has chronic pain
would know the frustration with that.
But I just know for me, my lens of who I am,
the answer is gonna be in this mystical journey for me.
And so, anyway, getting back to sexuality,
it's come back into my forefront,
that I am going to participate in rewriting
the way that we experience sexuality,
the way that we interact with that force.
Because it is literally our treasure,
and because of the nature of it,
it's also been reversed and infiltrated,
even in the sexual,
like, honey I didn't mean to just tell you
on the therapist that,
I mean, on the podcast
that I'm gonna be a sex therapist now, but now-
It's sounding like that, I was about to say.
It's sounding like that.
No, but a lot of it's been also manipulated
because it's an easy place to manipulate
if you don't know how to create the energetic boundaries.
And I'm not talking about promiscuous use of this power.
I'm talking about very responsible, guarded, devotional,
sacred attunement with this power,
whether you're single,
whether you're in any variation of relationship
in any preference.
With consenting adults.
I love it.
I know you weren't expecting that.
See, we haven't talked.
We talked a little bit about this.
I'm not surprised to hear you talk about that.
I'm interested to see where that goes.
Well, why don't we take a quick break,
and then we'll come back with lots more cool stuff?
Okay, let's do it.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But first, I do wanna snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about,
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is,
most people I know actually aspire to eat better,
to incorporate more whole plants,
fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
And so, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everyone to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of customizable,
super delicious, easy-to-prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
seven days a week,
and many, many other amazing features.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff.
Literally for just $1.70 a week, price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, back to the pod.
So, I went to the bathroom during the break
and then I came back and you said
that you dropped the best pearls of the podcast
while I was in the restroom.
No, well, Jason was just saying that he got a few,
he got a few pearls.
He was saying that, "Let it be beautiful,"
that he really liked that.
I just think that's really, really beautiful, actually,
because it wouldn't all of us like the permission
to experience a beautiful life
and know that that is spiritual?
Well, whatever happens is a thing.
It's all about the meaning that we attach to it
and the perspective and the opinions that we form around it,
which when they're quote-unquote
things that aren't going well,
we then develop shame.
We develop fear.
We develop a low self esteem
or sense that we're not good enough,
or all of these things began to pile on.
And then suddenly that event or whatever it is
becomes this living, breathing entity
that is working at cross-purposes
with your own personal evolution.
When really, you're the co-creator.
If you wanna create a beautiful life,
you have the power to apply a perspective in any situation.
It's not easy, it takes work.
And I'm not saying you don't feel pain.
I wasn't standing, sitting with this individual
who came to me in the face of his friend's suicide
and denying his grief.
I'm not doing that.
We're fully going into it.
We're fully sitting with it.
But we're choosing to apply a higher meaning to it.
And through that,
there is transcendence and there is evolution.
And something that was the most horrifying act
could become the most beautiful act
because of what it catalyzes for the future.
I just did a podcast with this woman the other day.
I was a guest on her podcast.
Her name is Alison Hadden.
She was introduced to me by Andy Puddicombe,
the Headspace founder.
Alison is somebody who is suffering terribly
from cancer at the moment.
Her body is riddled with cancer
and she's had multiple bouts with it.
And it's serious, very serious.
But rather than sit at home and feel sorry for herself,
she started this thing called "No Time to Waste".
She's got this podcast and she's like,
"I wanna talk to all these cool people
"that I respect or whatever."
She reached out to me,
and it was an amazing conversation.
But what I took away from that was just,
the choices that she's made about how she's interpreting
what has happened to her that she didn't ask for.
And you could say, like, "Oh, she co-created it,"
because perhaps there's some larger mystical purpose
for her enduring this hardship.
But it did happen to her.
It didn't happen because
she did anything to invite that into her life.
Her personality wasn't like, "I want to have this."
And she could very easily play the victim,
and she's not.
She had the most positive outlook on everything.
And she's like, "This is what I wanna do,
"and I'm not gonna sit at home,
"and like, I'm doing this thing."
It was very inspiring
and it really helped me reframe,
obviously, somebody like that is gonna help you
put things into perspective.
I just found it to be really powerful.
That's very inspiring and very beautiful.
And yeah, I mean, all we have is this present moment.
So, who knows?
I mean, the world could blow up tomorrow
or I could leave here and die in a car crash.
Anything can happen.
It's a mystery, we don't know.
She could have a spontaneous healing and not die at all,
or she could transition and go into another realm
where life is a different experience.
And you know, the-
She told me, sorry to interrupt.
She emailed me a couple hours
before we were supposed to record.
And she said, "I can't hear in either of my ears.
"I have to go to the hospital.
"There's a good chance
"that I'm gonna have to postpone the podcast."
'Cause she thought she might have
to go into emergency brain surgery,
that she had another tumor in her brain
that was pushing against her ear canals or something.
It turned out to not be that,
but she was fully expecting that.
She's apologizing for perhaps having to postpone
scheduling this thing.
And I was like, "That's unbelievable."
So profound.
Anyway, sorry.
I did step on what you were trying to say.
No, it doesn't matter.
That's amazing.
It's incredible.
Let's talk about some other stuff.
You wanna bring us up to speed on SriMu?
On SriMu?
I actually have a,
I have a pre-announcement.
My team is maybe gonna be really mad at me,
but I feel really good about this.
Well,
we have worked very hard
to refine our margins and to improve
our shipping channels, our distribution.
Our production is phenomenal.
I am so proud of my Sacred Makers.
As the Mother Arc.
I'm the Mother Arc of my Sacred Makers.
It's just such an amazing product.
I'm so honored to be the one to bring this through.
I've created really just this artisanal cheese,
NOT Cheese, that rivals dairy cheese.
And the reviews are just crazy.
I mean, I actually brought one wheel from Erewhon Markets.
I wanna give a shout out to Erewhon.
They are the only retailer that I'm in right now.
And Victor, one of the managers at Calabasas,
was telling me that the customers raving about it
is one of the most fun things that he's experiencing.
Anyway, in Erewhon we have three flavors,
but we now have four different box offerings.
One of the exciting things is later on in May,
we're going to have a two-wheel,
which is gonna be
a really great offering for a lot of people.
I should just say for people
that perhaps are newer to the show,
SriMu is your plant-based cheese company,
artisanal wheels of cheese
that is the evolution of cheese.
It's the next evolution of cheese.
Next evolution of cheese.
But if you like your Camemberts and your Bries,
and you like that really fine aged wheel of cheese
with your wine or your bread or whatever,
this is the plant-based version of that
that's better than anything you could possibly imagine.
But your business, Erewhon aside,
is essentially a subscription box service.
People go to the website SriMu.com, S-R-I-M-U.com.
And you launched with a large box that had,
I think four wheels and two balls?
Yeah, it had four wheels,
and then it had a jar of fresh mozzarella
that's called the Cloud 9
which is shipped in salted water, crystal-salted waters.
And then there was,
there is a Bonfire,
which is a smoked almond cheddar.
It's not your grandma's cheese ball.
Anyway, that's the big Sacred box offering,
which is this one.
But then we have a four-wheel box, a three-wheel box,
and now a two-wheel box of just the wheels.
Can you pick which cheeses you want in the two-wheel?
We're gonna have a little bit of customization
in a couple of the boxes.
In general, no, you can't,
but we allocate it really well
so that you can choose which product you like.
And you're shipping just domestic US, right?
Well, that's kind of the pre-sort-of-announcement.
Canada people, it looks like we are going to be able
to open up shipping to you very shortly,
so stay tuned.
You guys have been amazing.
I love the Canadian support and love for SriMu.
There's a lot of support in Canada.
It seems like all the energy
is coming from Canada right now.
I really like it, really, really like it.
Anyway, we did it successfully.
The boxes arrived.
We figured out the customs processes and everything.
And so, it feels like it's gonna be a go.
So, anyway, that's sort of a pre-announcement.
But stay tuned,
'cause we're looking forward to doing that.
And then actually, I wanted to mention,
so SriMu is aligning with different initiatives
that support the planet, that celebrate the planet.
And many of you know about my-
Can I eat this?
Yeah, please.
My spiritual alignment with Damanhur,
the spiritual community in Northern Italy near Turin.
And if you haven't checked them out,
please do check out Damanhur, D-A-M-A-N-H-U-R,
and take a tour of the temples.
They built temples to mankind inside a mountain in secret.
And when you speak to them,
they say, "It only took us 19 years."
It's this beautiful artistic offering
that is energetically benefiting the planet.
And the great mission of SriMu
is to collaborate with Damanhur,
so we have plans to produce SriMu EU in Damanhur,
and have been working on that.
The pandemic slowed us down a bit,
but that's still moving forward.
But the greater vision of Damanhur
is to create the next evolution of the temples,
which is this large living library
that is to house all of the indigenous teachings
on planet earth.
And if you understand spirituality and ceremony and ritual,
you know how vital these practices are
to the upliftment of humanity, the planet,
nature, animals.
And this project is massive.
It's going to be 120 times larger
than the 6,000 square meter underground temple
they have now.
SriMu's global mission is to participate
in building that with them.
So, that's the why behind SriMu.
And then recently,
I met up with my friend Natasha Severino
who is a makeup artist that I met from Lucy and Jan.
And Natasha did my makeup, I think twice,
and had a very profound spiritual awakening.
She changed her whole life over a two-year period,
and she started working with a shaman
who is very connected with the Hopi Nation.
And recently we worked together,
and she reached out and just said:
Julie, SriMati, the Hopi are suffering terribly
because of COVID.
They are in an area that does not receive
governmental support,
and they need clean water and they need compost toilets.
120 of their tribe have transitioned during this time,
and there's only 12,000 Hopi that live, that are alive.
And so, SriMu is gonna align with them
and we're going to help to get support
for these very, very magnificent,
sacred, sacred members of our human family.
Yeah, that's very cool.
I mean, I don't know a lot about the Hopi predicament,
but if I'm not mistaken,
they were not provided with reservation land, correct?
That's what I understand.
They ended up settling
in the midst of the Navajo Nation.
It's like in the center,
and as I understand it, and I'm not an expert in any way,
but there's a ring of Navajo,
or Dine is the is the correct term for that tribe.
But they're in the center.
And as I understand it,
the reason they were not placed by the government
is that they refuse to allow mining on their land.
So, they've just been there without governmental support,
and now the runoff of the mining from the Dine land
has contaminated all of their water supply.
And so, once again,
we have these very dire conditions on planet earth
due to our lifestyle and the things that we do,
and getting back to very basic human rights.
Human right to have clean water and food
and shelter and land.
And these, in the spiritual realms,
the Hopi are very sacred beings
that hold a certain coding and energetic.
I don't know it,
I haven't interacted with it in a great,
in a deep way,
but I do know that they are valued,
treasured indigenous frequencies that we need to care for.
They also have the dopest traditional attire.
The dopest, yeah, you've ever seen.
You guys can see it.
The water thing is real, though.
I mean, so many of them don't have clean water.
Arsenic is a huge problem.
I think there's something like 27% of them
that don't even have complete plumbing,
18% with no running water,
and some villages have no tap water at all.
It's quite a crisis.
I think there are some,
there is some assistance that's happening right now.
I don't know the status of that.
Well, Natasha works with a shaman, Marza,
and she's on the ground and has interacted
with this particular tribe
and many other indigenous all over the world.
And so, she's there in communion with them.
You can't just contact,
you can't just call them up like they're,
they live in their sacred ways.
Another thing that they're suffering from
is that they have very specific rites
when somebody transitions
and they're not able to do those rites now because of COVID.
There is a GoFundMe,
and we need support for anybody
that also has water solutions or compost toilet solutions,
any sustainability genius
or anybody who feels called to support in this way.
But money will help.
And I think they're trying to raise initially,
like, 50 grand to just get them the water that they need
and the waste processing.
All right, well,
I'll link up that GoFundMe in the show notes.
Also, if you've never heard of Damanhur
and you wanna learn a little bit more
about that wild, amazing place,
I think the website is just damanhur.it, right?
Do damanhur.foundations.
And there's a nonprofit link that you can donate there
and you can take a little mini tour of the temple.
It's quite extraordinary.
Do we wanna talk about Lorcan a little bit?
We do, let's talk about Lorca.
Lorca.
We call him Lorca.
Lorcan O'Herlihy is a beautiful artist,
architect, designer, fine artist, painter,
professor of architecture.
And he's the mastermind that designed our home
which we've gone into in the past on the podcast.
I don't know that we need to recount that whole story.
But he's become a dear friend,
and over the many years that have transpired
since he built our house,
his architecture firm, LOHA, L-O-H-A,
has matured from designing single-family homes
into large urban projects
with a very socially conscious bent to them.
And he's got this new book out
called "Architecture Is a Social Act".
Of course, it's a beautiful book
because he's a beautiful artist.
And it's a very cool primer
on how the spaces we design
are so influential in our lives,
which is something we've talked about with our home
that we're very blessed to live in.
But it's really about this direct connection between
the development of consciously-designed buildings
and the wider impact of them
and efforts to tackle issues that are relevant
in our rapidly-changing world.
Definitely.
And I mean, I think it ties right back
to the first spiritual tenet,
which is to live a beautiful life.
And Lorcan was over a couple of days ago
and I hadn't seen him in a long time.
He brought the book and I just,
again, once again acknowledged him
for being the sort of unsung healer and influencer
of our creative expressions in our family,
because his architecture has framed
our experience of the world.
And he looked at the containers that you have your office in
and that we have there.
He was telling me about this container structure
that he designed, which is for homeless.
And it's like, you look at that and you say,
well, why shouldn't everybody be able
to experience beauty in their space,
even if they're homeless?
We can still,
we don't just have to leave it to haphazard
and do it without intention.
If somebody had a beautiful Zen space,
even if it was very modest,
that might allow them the energy that they need
or the experience or the influence that they need
to find strength inside of themselves,
or remember that they have a creative thing to express
or lift them up.
So, we don't have to just let it go.
And I think I didn't realize just what a privilege it was
to have him design our house
until we had lived in it for 15 years.
But I think it's one of the most profound, impactful,
and best decisions that we ever made
was to work with an architect.
And I think architects should be revered,
because if you consider spaces as temples or as sanctuaries,
it's the places where we become.
It's the places where we find ourselves.
Architecture is a very key part of our life.
Yeah, I mean,
our home is the crucible
from which we have created everything,
from our children to all of these expressions
that we share with the world.
Recipes.
SriMu was created there.
That just on a very fundamental level is true.
The podcast.
But just the experience of
and the great, great privilege
of living in a beautiful place
and how that impacts how you think about your life
and pursue the things that are important to you.
It is profound.
And it's been beautiful to watch Lorcan who,
from the get-go, we knew was a genius
to see him embrace the social implications of his work
and to scale up what he's doing to the betterment
of society and culture at large,
Like, to reimagine what low-income housing
can look like, right?
It doesn't have to be the projects,
an uninspiring brick building that becomes a breeding ground
for all kinds of unhealthy behaviors,
but instead an uplifting and inspiring space
that's built affordably,
that can provide a refuse for so many people
that are need right now.
I mean, he's done all kinds of,
I mean, I think he's done,
has he done any museums yet?
But he's done bus stops,
simple things in Santa Monica, right?
Like the bus, like how can we make the bus stop
cool and inspiring and uplifting,
as opposed to just a bench?
Yeah, and he's,
I mean, he's done commercial buildings
and apartment buildings and huge public buildings
in China and also in Ireland.
He's a global architect
and more focused on the institution,
on the culture, on the community.
I think we were one of the last
single-family homes that he did.
I think we might've been the last one.
We might've been the last.
And our home is featured in his book
on page 36 or something.
We have a nice spread.
Cool, well, we love you, Lorcan.
Yeah, Lorcan, we love you.
"Architecture Is a Social Act", yes indeed.
Yes, and he's the best.
And we also wanted to shout out our friend Tracee Stanley.
She's got this beautiful new book, "Radiant Rest",
which is really about yoga nidra.
It is yoga nidra.
Okay, so if any of you guys have been
on our retreats to Italy,
you'll know that one of the most treasured workshops
that I teach is one on yoga nidra.
And it's always hilarious
because certain people start snoring
and you're supposed to stay-
I fall asleep every time.
Instantly, Rich is asleep and snoring.
And so, I usually do,
I offer a yoga nidra program out of the-
Gonna eat more of this.
The foundational book on the subject,
which is the Bihar School of Yoga,
which is just an amazing, amazing series of yoga books,
if you're interested.
And Tracee Stanley,
who is this radiant goddess, we've known her for years.
She's such a beautiful yoga teacher and meditator
and she has been studying and teaching yoga nidra
for many, many years.
And she wrote this beautiful book
bringing it into modern day.
And all of us should be practicing yoga nidra
every single day.
It's one of the most rejuvenative,
restorative, nourishing, immunity-building,
stress-reducing practices you could engage in.
And for those of you that have a hard time sitting,
you're lying down on the floor.
So, if you haven't
learned about yoga nidra or experienced it,
I would check out Tracee Stanley
and her book "Radiant Rest".
And for those that are perhaps
a little less spiritually inclined,
or for whom Julie is maybe a little bit more out there
than you're used to,
let me remind you that yoga nidra is something
that I talked about with Dr. Andrew Huberman,
who's a neuroscientist speaking about-
See, even somebody legitimate
like a neuroscientist.
So, if you need that to get your brain around it.
To feel validated.
If I'm too weird,
you could definitely do it with him.
So, what else is top of mind for you?
Let's see.
I think I've shared all my stuff.
I mean, the main thing for me is just,
that's really what's up for me right now.
Oh, you know what else?
I'm really enjoying putting together
a series of yoga practices.
I'm gonna be doing some videos.
I'm not sure who I'm gonna be doing them with yet,
but I really, really just,
you're talking about my practices
extending for hours during the day.
I just don't know what I would do in life
if I didn't have the tools and techniques
to get me into that space,
to allow me to commune to that with that energy.
And really, yoga practice, like asana yoga,
is at the foundation of everything
that I've done in my life.
I mean, it is the thing.
I mean, I met you in a yoga class.
So, taking the the need to get all into the lineage
and just offering it for me,
it's a way to get life force in the body,
life force in the body.
Still a very deep practice.
My practices are gonna bring you into an expanded presence.
It's not about light or quick movements,
or, I don't know.
It's not light.
But I really feel like we need practices to transform grief,
those of us that have said goodbye to our loved ones.
Especially during this time with so many restrictions
and so many questions,
we need a practice to process trauma.
So, what are the ancestral traumas that we have
in our life that we don't wanna carry on?
And what I want to share is that what we fail to clear
in our own beings,
our children will have to process that for us.
And I think that is a catalyzing moment,
a defining moment for me.
Right.
If you really think about that and embrace that,
nobody wants to pass onto their kids
something that has caused them pain.
But looking at that pain is so difficult.
But if you can imagine the possibility
that you can prevent your child
from having to contend with whatever it is
that you struggle with,
that is extra motivation to take a look at it.
Yeah, definitely.
And it's the responsibility again.
Nobody's going to do it for you
and you can't hide from yourself.
You can't pretend that something isn't going on
and just be like,
"Oh, I'm never gonna tell anybody
"and I'm just gonna keep this quiet."
Because you're just trying to fool yourself.
You can't hide from yourself.
It will come visit you somehow,
in this life, in another life.
But it's like, to not take responsibility
for our own things,
it just seems like is so irresponsible.
It's like, if we were alive, we have the opportunity.
We have to have the courage.
We have to have the courage to go in
and understand that no matter what happens,
it can be beautiful.
And it will be beautiful if you create it as such.
We need another practice to embody our best life,
to really connect with that natural, authentic blueprint
that is each one of us,
only one of us in the entire omniverse.
Not another Rich Roll anywhere.
What's the difference
between the omniverse and the multiverse?
In every, every, every universe, every universe.
But I mean, you gotta admit,
it's not that crazy when you go on NASA
and they're just finding planets left and right.
And humanity is so concerned over our political system,
and nobody even pays attention.
They're just like,
"Oh, a planet was discovered.
"No biggie."
But anyway, oh, just light in the body,
like communication between all of your organs.
What if your body was communicating with itself
completely functional all the time?
And many of us, if I say,
"Okay, close your eyes and imagine yourself,"
you might think of only your head.
So, how do we embody all of us as a breathing organism,
as a whole, as I say in yoga, whole body breathing?
Whole body breathe.
Right, right, yeah.
I mean, we have this notion that our consciousness
resides in our mind,
but actually, that's an illusion.
That's right.
There's no evidence to suggest
that it lives inside your mind.
But the mind has told you that it lives inside your mind.
Or that it lives inside your cranium, right?
It's interesting to,
there's a book about this called, I forget what it's called.
It's called something like, "Where's Your Head?"
or something like that.
I'm butchering it, but it goes into that subject.
And just in this moment,
I was speaking to somebody this week
about the shift in awareness.
The truth of the matter is we are in a new age.
That is true.
We are in the Aquarian Age now.
And so, one way we can look at it
is that everything that we did previous to now
was the first life.
And now everything that we're gonna do now
is the second life.
One of the qualities of this frequency that we're in
is before we would maybe have a goal, define it,
go out, grab it, conquer it, and achieve it, right?
It's like sort of a very linear
and masculine way of going about it.
And where you were asking me
at the beginning of this podcast,
how do you run a company when you're just meditating?
And the thing is that this frequency
is more of a feminine process and it's one of magnetism.
And so, again, I'll repeat,
there's nothing more powerful
than a being that knows itself.
And so, as you cultivate the ability to sit inside yourself,
to embody all that you are,
to take out everything you're hiding and look at it
and deal with it and resolve it and love it
and transform it or hold it,
you naturally attract the synchronic events
that are in alignment with the truth of who you are.
And so, that allows you to not struggle in work.
It's more of a relaxation into being.
The more I can relax and be who I am,
then suddenly the universe just floats by
with a silver platter.
And you're like,
"Oh yes, I'll have that order, thank you very much."
Yeah, I've had a taste of that in my life,
but it's so difficult for me
because I exist under the delusion
that if I don't suffer and feel pain
in the pursuit of something,
that I either don't deserve it
or I'm not working hard enough to get it.
We gotta help you with that.
It's like an addiction.
it's like the idea, like what if it was easy?
Like, what if writing that book was just easy?
I can't fathom that.
You're like, "No."
You don't want it.
Well, and also,
yeah, if it did come easy, then I would say,
"Well, that was too easy, it must not be good."
Like I need to go back and roll up my sleeves
and just really connect with the pain body.
Yeah, but I mean, the thing is,
even in that frequency doesn't mean everything's easy.
I mean, life still visits you.
Right, but the idea of the synchronic aspect
of what you just shared,
the idea being that you're in the flow
and you're inviting these things into your life.
It's more of an allowing as opposed to a forcing, right?
But I think you experience that a lot in your life,
especially now.
Maybe you just don't know it.
I still like to grind.
You like it.
There's a sense of satisfaction that comes with,
I left it all out on the field, right?
There's nothing more I could have done
to make that any better.
Well, I mean, I could tell you that about SriMu.
I mean, I didn't leave anything on the table.
I just did it in a different way.
I did it with a different bhava,
a different energy, I guess.
And I think there's something about that,
the differences that live and breathe between us
that creates something powerful about our union.
We had a joke the other day
because it was a Saturday morning
and I was getting ready to go out on my bike.
And I'm in my cycling kit
and my helmet and sunglasses and the whole thing.
And you came down from a meditation session
and you had sandalwood on your forehead.
I had ash on my forehead.
I was like, "Oh wow, we're both in our costumes."
Different costumes, yeah, that's funny.
And those costumes on some level are a manifestation
of some truth within each of us, but they're still costumes.
Sure, definitely.
Definitely.
And listen, again, it's about you being you.
It's about you embodying who you are.
And so, your truth may be to really just be in that.
And that's natural for you.
That's the way it is for you.
And you can marvel at me, but you don't have to judge me
and you don't have to wanna be like anybody else except you.
Right, I mean, you do the same to me.
You're like, "Wow, look at you.
"You're in that, look at that get-up you got on,"
or whatever.
It's like, you're never gonna get in a cycling kit
and go ride with me.
Exactly.
And I don't expect you to,
and I don't judge you for not wanting to do that.
Yeah, exactly,.
But here we are, 21 years later,
21 years into our relationship-
That's crazy.
Which makes us just by sheer time,
makes us relationship experts, you know?
And our relationship, our marriage
is surviving the pandemic.
So, for people, and maybe this is a final thing,
thread that we can pull on.
For people that are,
I mean, I can imagine if you're in a relationship
and you're stuck in a living space with somebody
and it's not going well,
how painful that must be.
I think that's a very common experience right now.
What's the answer?
No, well, it's more like what is,
let's just talk about tools for
navigating tricky relationships.
For us, so much of it is about communication.
I mean, we're well-suited to each other.
We were together forever before the pandemic,
so it's not like,
oh, we just met and now we're in an apartment.
But a lot of people are in that situation.
Well, I mean,
I think, again, this is a moment.
It's an opportunity.
It's a great shift.
Everybody's going through huge changes.
Our cultures, our systems, our money, our art,
the way art is sold, or travel.
We had a big conversation about NFTs with Mathis
at dinner the other night.
This is gonna,
as an art student, pay attention to this,
because this is gonna change the nature of art
and how it's valued.
Maybe you should explain that to the listeners.
Do you think they all know?
No, it's too-
You don't have time?
If you don't know what that means,
then we're just not gonna explain it to you.
So, the thing is it's a time of transformation.
This is what it is.
And so, I think many of you that are listening to this,
you know this within yourselves.
You know if you're at a crossroads
or if there's a choice that's come up for your review.
And I still maintain what I've always represented
and what has been the foundation of our relationship.
And that is you're here to live your life.
You're here to live what is inside of you.
The treasures are inside your own heart.
And so, it just leads me back to the beginning is,
you gotta look at whatever you're hiding from.
What are you hiding from?
You can't hide from yourself.
At some point you're going to have to experience,
interact with, reconcile.
And no matter how scary it is,
communication, first of all, with yourself
is the first step.
And then communication with those around you.
And hopefully,
it's not always easy for people
because not everybody are great communicators.
But if you can communicate what it is you're feeling,
and you know, you have the possibility
to rewrite the way relationships are.
Rewrite sexuality, rewrite what it means to be married.
I mean, for goodness sakes,
"No one's straight anymore,"
one of my kids said to me the other day.
He's like, "Mom, no one's straight."
It's like, we have all this sexual identity.
Everybody's pan, fluid, bi, whatever, transgender.
All this stuff's coming up.
And so, it's like,
we need to just love ourselves
and understand that it's gonna be okay
and that everything must change.
Everything has to go through a transformation.
And so, because I don't like suffering,
I want you to do it in the most gentle way possible.
I don't like humans to suffer.
I also think we should refrain
from an old idea of a patterning
that means X when someone breaks up.
That we can do this, people make fun of it.
You know, "Oh, I'm consciously uncoupling.
"Like, oh, that's so funny."
But it's actually,
if you really love somebody and you really love them,
then you would want what is best for them in all places,
in all stages of their life.
And you and I, our vows were to support each other
to realize our greatest dreams.
That was what we said.
And I think we've done that.
I think we've held up to that.
And every relationship is changing and moving.
It's not about where you were or the old story.
It's about who are we today
and what are we doing going forward
and what is left to be uncovered inside of me?
What is left to be uncovered inside of you?
And how can we support that?
So, I think it's all about you and you.
It's this deep communion with your own self.
And when you learn to advocate for yourself,
then you will make choices
that are considering yourself first,
which is rather contrary to the way we've been raised.
We think it's spiritual to martyr yourself, but no.
The martyr doesn't help anybody in the end.
So, wouldn't it be better to just honor yourself?
And you'll find out that if you start treating yourself
with that kind of respect and love and celebration,
that will be mirrored back to you.
Right, you will then attract a like-minded partner
who's vibrating on that level.
Or you'll just get energy that's supporting you.
Yeah, I mean, the instinct is,
I feel uncomfortable with who I am.
I'm gonna reach out and try to find somebody else
and bring them into my world to salve my pain
or my poor self-esteem or whatever it is
that I'm contending with.
And that's the upside-down way of going about it.
Be the person, become the person.
Commit yourself to becoming the person
that the person you aspire to be with
would wanna be with, right?
And then figure out,
and then that person will, if you do that,
that person will find their way into your life
without having to go on a dating app.
And should you find yourself in that precious situation,
it then becomes about honoring yourself
and honoring the best
of what that other person has to offer.
Which is very easy to say and very difficult to do.
Very complicated.
We have a friend who,
you told this story at dinner the other night
about being told to not be on a dating app anymore.
Oh, right, right, right.
I won't say who it is,
but, well, I don't even know.
I mean, dating apps, like we are totally the un-experts.
I got a question on "Roll On" the other day about that.
I was like, "I can't give any advice about dating apps."
No, we can't even speak to that, we're too old.
We're that generation.
We didn't do that.
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, again, everything in my estimation,
my best offering is it's all about building
an absolutely devotional relationship with yourself,
because there's nothing more beautiful
than a being that knows itself.
And there's no one else that is going
to find that connection except you.
No one's gonna do that work for you.
So, if you're compromising
or if you bonded with somebody over pain
and pain is the subject of your life,
you have the ability to transmute that,
to learn from it, to bless it, to thank it,
if you've learned enough from it.
If you haven't learned enough from it, then stay there.
I mean, there's valuable lessons to be learned
in all life experiences.
And it's not just about one tone.
But the main thing is, are you getting the lesson?
Are you transforming?
Did you take away something from it?
And then we have to make peace with our traumas.
I think that's a good place to land the plane,
as they say.
Thanks for inviting me on.
Beautifully eloquent and wise as always.
Thank you, honey.
Beautiful.
Julie Piatt AKA SriMati.
If you wanna learn more about her multiverse,
you should check out her podcast "For the Life of Me".
You can tap into her spiritual community Water Tiger,
and you can order her wonderful cheese at SriMu.com.
But all things SriMati can be found at juliepiatt.com,
and that's really it, right?
That's it.
Check out the cheese.
Check out the cheese, people.
You'll be happy.
All right,
how was your first studio experience in the RRP?
I felt very loved and cared for.
Good, come back.
I'm very in awe of what you have created in your life.
It's truly a beautiful, beautiful experience to watch that.
Thank you, but it doesn't happen without
the support and the belief
that you have demonstrated over the decades.
So, thank you for that.
It's my honor.
Love you.
Love you, babe.
Peace.
Namaste.